[Applauso]
immaginate di vivere in una società
molto evoluta dove una grande fetta
dell'economia gravita attorno a una
filiera agro industriale da una pianta
si ricavano alimenti tessuti carta
materiale isolante da costruzione il
tutto nel rispetto dell'ambiente e delle
persone
un ciclo annuale continuo che parte dal
campo con la coltivazione della preziosa
pianta passa dall industria per la sua
trasformazione e arriva a noi per il suo
utilizzo e successivo riciclo una
comunità di persone sane felici in
armonia e consapevoli della fortuna di
avere un dono dal cielo
sarebbe bello eh ma è evidente che si
tratta di un sogno di un'utopia
lasciamo perdere questa follia e
torniamo al giorno d'oggi
anzi torniamo indietro di vent'anni o
poco più
nel periodo che va tra la mia
adolescenza e la fine dell'università
ho vissuto con la mia famiglia in una
bella casetta sul lago di como era stata
costruita dai miei nonni negli anni 70
peccato che la mia camera non avesse
alcun tipo di isolamento fosse sopra in
garage non riscaldato e l'unica cosa che
mi ricordo era un cattivo comfort freddo
per sette mesi l'anno freddo e umido e
poi altri tre mesi di caldo afoso
il che mi lasciava solo due mesi
tipicamente maggio e settembre in cui mi
sentivo a mio agio
dopo qualche anno decidono di partire
per l'irlanda a frequentare un master in
sviluppo sostenibile non ho risparmi e
quindi mi gioco tutto con un prestito in
banca
chiaramente per sostentarsi durante quei
diciotto mesi di studio la strizza di
non riuscire a ripagare il debito si
trasforma in voglia di vivere al pieno
ogni singolo momento e fa nascere in me
la consapevolezza di avere tra le mani
l'opportunità di una vita mi immergo
nelle elezioni nel lavoro individuali
nei lavori di gruppo e nei libri
apprendo e collega tra loro gli enormi
problemi che l'astronave terra sta
affrontando e mi rendo anche conto che
le soluzioni già esistono ma che non
sono efficaci perché limitate nella
scala e quindi nell'impatto
durante la ricerca di un tema attorno al
quale sviluppare la tesi di master un
amico irlandese mi suggerisce di cercare
sul web le parole lime e am inizialmente
penso che si tratti di un cocktail
perché i online l'ho sempre trovato nel
mojito ma poi piano piano mi rendo conto
che lime deriva da lime stone roccia
calcarea e che si traduce con calce ampi
invece la canapa
io l'ho sempre conosciuta fin dall
adolescenza come cannabis o marijuana
beh ci siamo capiti trovo subito il tema
molto interessante e per questo motivo
decide di dedicare la tesi di master a
questa ricerca
piano piano scopro che meravigliandomi
la canapa industriale differisce dalla
marijuana per il suo basso contenuto di
thc il principio attivo contenuto nel
fiore è una pianta che ha sempre avuto
un ruolo importantissimo per migliaia di
anni soprattutto per la sua fibra veniva
descritta come la regina delle piante da
fibra lo standard con cui confrontare
tutte le altre fibre le applicazioni
tutte le parti della pianta vengono
valorizzate dal seme al fiore al fusto
si ricavano una miriade di prodotti
prodotti alimentari prodotti
farmaceutici cosmetici lettiere per
animali alcol combustibili materiali
isolanti e da costruzione ed è proprio
con quest'ultima
applicazione che le parole line end
hanno a che fare
man mano che approfondisca la ricerca
scopro che settore dell'edilizia è uno
tra i maggiori impattanti sull'ambiente
pensate che il 40 per cento delle
materie prime viene consumato in questo
settore il 50 per cento delle emissioni
di gas serra deriva dall edilizia
inoltre mi meraviglia anche il fatto che
70 per cento della spesa energetica
domestica è destinata totalmente il
riscaldamento non solo l'involucro degli
edifici in cui viviamo e lavoriamo e
spesso realizzato accoppiando materiali
diversi spesso di origine minerale come
laterizio la lana di roccia oppure
sintetici come i poliuretano o
polistirene non solo sono materiali con
un elevato impatto ambientale per via
del loro ciclo produttivo e per la loro
non riciclabilità ma sono materiali
praticamente impermeabili il vapore
acqueo prodotto all'interno degli
edifici non riesce ad attraversarli
quindi condensa e si trasforma in muffa
e questo va a ridurre in modo importante
la qualità dell'aria interna e la
performance dell'edificio
ce lo conferma l'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità che già nel 1986 ha coniato
il termine sindrome da edificio malsano
per identificare tutta quella serie di
disturbi ad esempio mal di testa
bruciore agli occhi irritazione delle
vie aeree irritazione della pelle che
derivano da una varietà di fattori tra
cui temperatura umidità ricambi d'aria
ed emissione di sostanze tossiche che
derivano dai materiali da costruzione o
dall'arredamento con un involucro in
canapa e calce la dinamica cambia
totalmente
l'intero spessore della muratura e
realizzato con un unico materiale non ci
sono interruzioni freni vapore o altri
materiali
si ottiene così una muratura monolitica
all'interno della quale
ore acqueo può muoversi liberamente
inoltre la canapa e molto porosa se si
ingrandisce al microscopio si notano una
serie di canali paralleli più fini di un
capello comunicanti tra loro attraverso
dei fori ancora più piccoli questa
particolare conformazione fa sì che il
vapore acqueo vada incontro a continue
micro evaporazioni e micro condensazioni
in grado di bloccare la dispersione
energetica in soli 6 cm
grazie a queste due caratteristiche la
temperatura e l'umidità all'interno
dell'edificio
restano sempre costanti e questo si
traduce in elevato comfort abitativo un
importante risparmio energetico ma
soprattutto in un ambiente molto salubre
più compositi di canapa e calce
tra l'altro sono molto durevoli non
contengono sostanze tossiche sono
biodegradabili sono riciclabili sono
riutilizzabili ed hanno un impatto
positivo sull'ambiente grazie alla
velocità con cui la pianta di canapa
sottrae co2 dall'atmosfera durante la
sua crescita si utilizzano sotto forma
di blocchi prefabbricati come questo
oppure con delle particolari macchine
che permettono di spruzzare la canapa e
la calce e produrre il mio composito
direttamente sul cantiere
se l'avessi saputo prima sarebbe stata
la soluzione ideale per risolvere i
problemi della mia cameretta fredda e
umida
per questo motivo decide di sfruttare la
tesi di master per capire meglio quali
siano i limiti allo sviluppo su larga
scala di questa splendida tecnologia in
italia è praticamente sconosciuta in
irlanda si sta iniziando a parlare nel
regno unito solo alcuni progetti
sperimentali
in francia invece è l'unico paese dove
si trovano gia alcuni esempi la storia
narra che nel 1986 un muratore maestro
muratore di nome charlie st
fu il primo ad utilizzare un
biocomposito di canapa e calce per il
restauro di un edificio storico del 1600
da quel momento la tecnica inizia a
raccogliere interesse e viene sviluppata
e testata in tutta un'altra serie di
applicazioni anche il mondo accademico
contribuisce con la ricerca scientifica
a spiegare nel dettaglio il
comportamento di questo materiale
divoro qualsiasi materiale
sull'argomento e piano piano mi rendo
conto e concludo la tesi identificando i
limiti allo sviluppo di questa
tecnologia nella mancanza di
informazioni per gli operatori di
settore e nella mancanza di
certificazioni sono così convinto di
avere così informazione a disposizione
che nel 2011 decide di tornare in italia
e grazie al prezioso supporto di un
business angel di un socio tecnico con
esperienza di cantiere e di altri due
soci investitori bilancio nel tentativo
di innovare un settore nel pieno della
sua crisi economica ad oggi oltre 500
famiglie vivono in case realizzate con
un involucro in canapa e calce
abbiamo ricevuto diversi riconoscimenti
nel 2015
abbiamo anche depositato un brevetto che
copre un'ampia gamma di applicazioni
quello che vedete è il complesso
residenziale case di luce a bisceglie in
puglia è il più grande edificio al mondo
con un involucro in canapa e calce in
cui efficienza energetica e salubrità
dell'aria raggiungono gli standard più
elevati e l'intero fabbisogno energetico
è coperto da fonti di energia
rinnovabile non ci sono più limiti e
barriere allo sviluppo di questa
tecnologia infatti crediamo che nel 2020
diventerà uno degli standard costruttivi
ed isolamento in italia e nel mondo
fortunatamente a breve inizieranno anche
i lavori per migliorare la qualità
abitativa dell'edificio dei miei
genitori di casa nostra è la mia
cameretta diventerà il look
più confortevole di tutto il lago di
como
all'inizio vi ho parlato di una società
evoluta e io ho immaginato una società
in grado di valorizzare una pianta
collocandola all'interno di un processo
produttivo con l'obiettivo di rigenerare
persone natura e ambiente
dopotutto non sembra così lontana grazie